PROSPERITY, NEVER FORGET THE
FORGOTTEN MEN AND WOMEN OF THIS
COUNTRY.
JOINING US KNOW WHAT THE
REACTION IS THE RANKING
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN
NUNES IS WITH US.
YOUR REACTION TO ALL THIS.
I SAY BECAUSE IT'S SO
ILLEGITIMATE, SO UNFAIR, SO
UNCONSTITUTIONAL, REPUBLICANS
SHOULD NOT PLAY A PART OF THIS
IN MY OPINION.
YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> WELL, I THINK YOU NAILED IT
ON THE HEAD, SEAN, WE HAVE TO
HAVE AT LEAST ONE MEMBER OF
CONGRESS AND AT LEAST ONE LAWYER
TO TAKE NOTES SO WE KNOW WHAT
THEY ARE SAYING.
IF NOT, IF THEY DO CONTROL THE
GAVEL, THEY HAVE THE POWER AND
THEY CAN DO A LOT OF REALLY BAD
THINGS.
LOOK, I FIND IT INTERESTING THAT
PELOSI IS NOT EVEN GOING TO
BOTHER TO TRY TO FIGHT THE
ADMINISTRATION AND TAKE THIS TO
COURT.
I THINK THAT'S NEW INFORMATION.
I'M SURPRISED AT THAT.
BUT THAT MEANS THEY REALLY ARE
JUST RACING TO GET THIS DONE.
FINALLY WHAT I THINK YOU ARE
SEEING IS THEY ARE ON A SUGAR
HIGH WITH POLES RIGHT NOW.
THEY'VE GOT 90% OF THE MEDIA
POISONING PEOPLE.
THEY'VE GOT ALL THE TECH
COMPANIES POISONING PEOPLE.
THEY READ THE POLLS AND AS LONG
AS IT'S 50% PLUS 12 IMPEACH THE
PRESIDENT.
I THINK YOU SAID A ROCKET DOCKET
IMPEACHMENT.
THAT'S WHAT THEY ARE GOING FOR
IT.
>> Sean: I WANT TO ASK YOU
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT UKRAINE.
WE ALL READ THE TRANSCRIPT,
THERE'S NOTHING THERE, THERE IS
NO NEED FOR A NONWHISTLE-BLOWER
WHISTLE-BLOWER.
I WANT TO GET YOUR REACTION BUT
WE DO HAVE BIDEN ON TAPE
BRAGGING ABOUT LEVERAGING IN THE
SHAKE DOWN A BILLION DOLLARS OF
TAXPAYER MONEY TO FORCE UKRAINE
TO FIRE A UKRAINIAN PROSECUTOR
IN SIX HOURS AND HE SIGNED AN
AFFIDAVIT SAYING THAT'S WHY HE
GOT FIRED OR HE'S NOT GIVING
THEM THE MONEY.
OKAY?
THAT SOUNDS LIKE SOMETHING
REALLY SERIOUS TO ME.
>> YEAH.
THAT'S WHY I BELIEVE IF JOHN
SOLOMON'S REPORTING IS CORRECT
FROM YESTERDAY, THEY'VE
ACTUALLY -- THE UKRAINIANS HAD
ACTUALLY REOPENED THAT THIS
INVESTIGATION LONG BEFORE TRUMP
HAD EVER TALKED TO THE NEW
UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT.
SO THAT COULD BE ONGOING.
IF YOU LOOK AT ALL THE
HAPPENINGS IN UKRAINE OVER THE
LAST FEW YEARS, IT'S VERY
CONCERNING.
I HOPE -- THEY ARE SUPPOSED TO
BRING IN THE FORMER AMBASSADOR
TO UKRAINE FROM THE
UNITED STATES, SHE IS SUPPOSED
TO COME IN ON FRIDAY.
I DON'T KNOW IF SHE IS GOING TO
COME IN OR NOT, BUT WE ARE
LOOKING FORWARD TO HAVING HER IN
BECAUSE YOU PROBABLY KNOW, PETE
SESSIONS FORMER
CONCERNS THAT SHE WAS NOT
SERVING THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
WELL IN UKRAINE, SO SHE WAS
REMOVED.
WE HAVE SEEN LOTS OF BRAGGING IN
THE PRESS THAT SHE'S GOING TO BE
THE ONE WHO REALLY BRINGS DOWN
THE PRESIDENT.
>> Sean: I HAVE QUESTIONS
BECAUSE MY SOURCES ARE TELLING
ME THAT THE FORMER U.S.
AMBASSADOR TO UKRAINE, MY LITTLE
BERTIE IS WHISTLING TO ME, I DO
NOT KNOW IF IT'S TRUE OR NOT
YET, BUT I'M LOOKING, BUT IS
THERE EVIDENCE SHE MAY HAVE USED
GOVERNMENT RESOURCES TO MONITOR
COMMUNICATIONS OF AMERICAN
CITIZENS AND YOU KNOW IF ANY
OF THE CITIZENS MIGHT'VE BEEN
JOURNALISTS?
>> WHAT I CAN TELL YOU IS WE
KNOW WHAT PETE SESSIONS,
CONGRESSMAN FROM TEXAS NOW
RETIRED, WE KNOW WHAT HE HAS TO
SAY.
WE KNOW THERE ARE PEOPLE WITHIN
THAT WERE NOT ONLY UKRAINIANS
BUT ALSO AMERICANS WHO WORKED ON
THE STATE DEPARTMENT WHO HAVE
RAISED CONCERNS ABOUT THIS
AMBASSADOR WHICH IS WHY SHE WAS
ULTIMATELY REMOVED.
WE ALSO HAVE CONCERNS THAT
POSSIBLY WE WERE MONITORING THE
PRESS FROM DIFFERENT JOURNALISTS
AND OTHERS.
THAT WE DON'T KNOW, WE HAVE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE GIVEN US THIS
INFORMATION AND WE ARE GOING TO
ASK THESE QUESTIONS TO THE
STATE DEPARTMENT AND HOPEFULLY
THEY WILL GET THE ANSWERS BEFORE
SHE COMES IN ON FRIDAY.
BUT WE WILL GIVE HER AN
OPPORTUNITY --
>> Sean: OKAY, BECAUSE WHAT
YOU ARE SAYING IS VERY ALARMING
TO ME.
I HAVE THREE PEOPLE NOW THAT
HAVE TOLD ME THAT THEY BELIEVE
THAT THERE IS EVIDENCE THAT SHOW
GOVERNMENT RESOURCES WERE USED
TO MONITOR COMMUNICATIONS, IN
ONE CASE A JOURNALIST THAT IS A
REGULAR ON THIS PROGRAM WITH THE
NAME JOHN SOLOMON.
HAVE YOU HEARD THAT,
CONGRESSMAN?
>> WHAT I HAVE HEARD, AND I WANT
TO BE CLEAR.
I THINK THERE IS A DIFFERENCE.
WHAT I HEARD IS THERE WERE A
STRANGE REQUEST, REGULAR REQUEST
TO MONITOR NOT JUST ONE
JOURNALIST BUT MULTIPLE
JOURNALISTS.
NOW PERHAPS THAT WAS OKAY.
PERHAPS THERE WAS SOME REASON
FOR THAT, IT CAN BE EXPLAINED
AWAY.
BUT THAT'S WHAT WE KNOW AND
THAT'S WHAT WE ARE GOING TO BE